es ella contra el sistema de salud de
China Teresa escritora de 35 años
demandó al hospital de ginecología de
Beijing por violar sus derechos
reproductivos tras negarse a congelar a
sus óvulos por ser soltera en 2019
Espero que más gente pueda reconocer que
existe una diversidad de mujeres
solteras que tienen derecho a la
autonomía reproductiva y a tomar
decisiones sobre su cuerpo y su
reproducción
el año pasado Teresa perdió un juicio al
respecto en Beijing que dictaminó que el
hospital no violó sus derechos pero con
esta última apelación aún tiene
esperanzas de ganar aunque su principal
objetivo es otro arrojar luz sobre esta
problemática entre las mujeres solteras
y las parejas no heterosexuales en el
país ya que los tratamientos de
fertilidad como la fecundación in vitro
y la congelación de óvulos solo se
contemplan para matrimonios que tienen
dificultades para concebir
no quiero rendirme fácilmente Además
desde este año algunas noticias dan
indicio de cambios en las políticas
favorables a las mujeres solteras
y es que la sentencia final Será muy
importante para los derechos
reproductivos de las mujeres pero
independientemente de esta la
preocupación por el envejecimiento de la
población podría cambiar la situación
algo por lo que en marzo el gobierno
chino propuso que las mujeres solteras
tuvieran acceso a estos tratamientos